مصدر في سرايا القدس للجزيره يتحدث بان
الشهداء في شرق خان يونس ليسوا من سرايا
القدس ما الذي يعنيه مثل هذا الامر وائل
هذا يعنيه وضع للنقاط على الحروف ودفعا
لكل حالات الجدل والمغالطات ونشر او
التسرع في نشر الروايات منها ما هو منسوب
الى الاعلام الاسرائيلي منها ما هو منسوب
لشهود وعيان لم يتاكدوا منها ما هو منسوب
الى اوساط غير معروفه غير معلومه
يتناقلها بعض النشطاء ينشرون على مواقع
السوشيال ميديا والفيسبوك وغيرها من
المواقع وبالتالي تلتقطها وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه وسائل الاعلام تنشر هذه
المعلومات
وبالتالي الوسائل الاعلام الفلسطينيه تنقل
عن وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه وكانها
معلومات استخباريه وامنيه وندخل في هذه
الدوامه ويعيش الشارع الفلسطيني حاله من
الارباك اكثر مما هي موجوده فعلا بسبب هذه
التناقضات والشائعات التي في نهايه المطاف
تضر بمصالح المواطن الفلسطيني ونفسيته
ومعنويته وتصب في مصلحه الحرب والمعنويه
التي تشنها اسرائيل اساسا على الشارع
الفلسطيني مستغله مثل هذه التناقضات هذه
التصريحات المنسوبه للمصدر الذي تحدثتم
عنه هو محاوله لوضع النقاط على الحروف وهو
يعني ربما يصب في في مصلحه الاعلام الرصين
ان صح التعبير الذي يستقل معلومات من
مصادره الاكيده الرسميه بعد يعني تقص
الحقائق والحصول على معلومات اكيده
وبالتالي نشرها على الشاشات والفضائيات
والشبكات التلفزه ولذلك كنا حذرين في نشر
اسماء
يعني معلومات
وبالمناسبه هي بحوزتنا منذ فتره طويله
اسماء كثيره ترددت وروايات كثيره ترددت
لكن لم نعمد الى نشرها لانها ببساطه غير
مؤكده الان هذه المصادر تؤكد هذا هذا هذا
التوجه وهو التوجه كما قلنا الرصين
والصحيح والاكيد والذي يجب ان ينتهجه كل
الاعلام ووسائل الاعلام المختلفه وعليه
نحن سلمى الان امام اعاده تاكيد المعلومه
الاكيد الوحيد في هذه القضيه التي
اثيرت حولها كثير من الشاعات والروايات
وحاله الجدل بالتاكيد هو وصول شهيدين الى
المستشفى في خان يونس وهي عباره عن اشلاء
متفحمه وواضح بان الصور كانت صادمه
والاستهداف مباشر وبالتالي اشتعلت النيران
من كان بداخل السياره احترق بالكامل وتفحم
وتناثر وكل هذه الاوصاف المفزعه والمرعبه
لكن اكثر من ذلك لا يوجد معلومات اكيده
ونهائيه لا بخصوص هويه الشهيدين ولا حتى
الجهه التي ينتمون اليها